- [Instructor] In 1890, the
United States was not exactly
a major player on the world stage.
It was an industrial behemoth,
attracting immigrants
from all over the world,
but it was focused on
its own internal growth,
not foreign affairs.
There was little in the way
of a shared popular culture,
and there was practically
no government regulation
of industry or the market.
Compare that to the United states in 1945,
which had a bustling
shared national culture,
a social safety net, and
lots of industry regulations
brought on by depression and war.
And the United States was the
strongest nation on earth.
For a time, the world's lone atomic power.
These are all enormous changes,
changes in ideas about the economy,
American culture, and the United
States' role in the world.
As a historian,
I'm curious about how these changes
affected American national
identity during this period.
National identity is a
bit of a slippery thing,
but it encompasses a lot of core values
and beliefs in society
about who counts as an American,
how Americans should act,
and how the United States should
relate to other countries.
So how can we measure just how much impact
the events of the first
half of the 20th century had
on American national identity.
First, we need to get more specific
about which core beliefs
around national identity
we wanna track,
since one of the changes we're looking at
relates to the growing regulation
of the American economy
in this time period.
One belief I think would be
valuable to examine over time
is individualism.
This is the idea that
everyone should be able
to pull themselves up by their bootstraps
to earn a good living
through their own hard work.
This has been a pretty core
American value over time,
but there certainly have been moments
when many have question whether
it can really be achieved.
Next, I'm curious about changes
in American cultural
identity over this period.
People did a lot of moving around
in the early 20th century,
going from farms to cities,
and from the old country to the new.
So did the United States develop a shared
national culture in this time
period along with the advent
of new communication
technologies like the radio,
or were cultural values
in the United States
fractured along lines of
race, class, and ethnicity?
Finally, since this is the era in which
the United States grew into a world power,
I'd like to look at changes in beliefs
about what the proper US
role in the world should be.
Okay, now that we've
decided which core values
of national identity we wanna track,
let's brain storm some of the major events
that may have affected these
values during this period.
I encourage you to pause the video here,
and think about what events
you might wanna discuss
related to these themes.
Think about the big things
that happened in this era
and how they could affect
ideas about individualism,
culture, and the United
States' role in the world.
You may come up with some
different things than I do,
and that's okay.
Remember, we're doing a high-level
overview of events here,
so I'm not gonna go into
much depth about any of them.
But if I mention something
you're not familiar with,
just jot it down,
and you can follow up
on that concept later.
Okay, first, let's look at
beliefs around individualism.
This is really a question
about whether people thought
it was possible for them
to earn a good living
through hard work alone.
In the 1890s, there were
a few questions about
whether industrialization
and business consolidation
was making it impossible for
ordinary people to succeed,
like the farmers who
supported the Populist Party,
and wanted the government
to regulate railroads
and alter the money supply.
But they didn't get too much traction.
The progressive era also introduced
some regulations on business,
with presidents like Teddy
Roosevelt busting trusts,
and reformers helping to pass laws
protecting workers and consumers.
The Roaring Twenties, by contrast,
was an era of boundless optimism
about the individual's
ability to get wealthy.
With lots of ordinary folks
investing in the stock market,
and believing that the
economic boom would never end,
but of course it did end,
and with it,
so did a lot of people's
faith in individualism.
Factors outside the
control of any one person
brought on the great depression,
and people looked to the government
to provide relief to citizens
in a way that it had never done before.
The new deal established
a social safety net
and a limited welfare state
that would influence the
American economy for decades.
So looking at this period as a whole,
it seems like the events of the first half
of the 20th century had
a pretty profound effect
on the belief in American individualism.
Industrialization and
then the Great Depression
led to a growing sense that
the modern industrial economy
was too large of a machine for individuals
to navigate it successfully on their own.
And therefore, the government had a duty
to see to the welfare of its citizens.
Next, let's examine American
culture over this time period.
Was there one shared national culture,
like the melting pot analogy
or were there many tensions
and divisions in culture
over things like ideas, race,
religion, or gender roles.
During this time period,
migration to cities led to the development
of cultural enclaves, like Little Italy,
and new cultural movements
like the Harlem Renaissance.
Those might suggest a
more divided culture.
On the other hand, the growing popularity
of radio and cinema in the 1920s
contributed to the development
of a national culture where
people across the country
could watch the same movies,
listen to the same radio shows,
and root for the same sports starts.
But there was also a backlash
against immigrant culture
and the urban modern environment
with the re-emergence of the KKK,
restrictions on freedom of speech,
and calls for 100% Americanism
during World War I,
and emigration restrictions in the 1920s.
However, American propaganda
during World War II
emphasize the diversity
and inclusiveness of the United States,
in contrast to Nazi racial ideology.
And US culture became more
accepting toward immigrants
from European backgrounds.
But Asian-Americans and African-Americans
were so largely excluded.
So the cultural transition
of the United States
is a bit of a mixed bag
in this time period.
There were both elements
that brought the country together
in a shared national culture,
and elements that
divided it based on race,
ethnicity, and belief.
Last, let's look at beliefs about
the role of the United
States in the world.
Up until the Spanish-American war in 1898,
the guiding US foreign
policy was isolationism,
staying out of world affairs.
But by the turn of the 20th century,
the US government was tempted
to get in on the imperial game,
like the great powers of Europe,
and it did so with the
acquisition of Cuba,
Hawaii, and the Philippines.
United States was also reluctant
to get involved in World War I,
and did so only very late in
the war, after provocation.
After World War I,
the United States return to
its policy of isolationism
throughout the 1920s and 1930s,
but the Japanese bombing
of Pearl Harbor in 1941
led the country to fully mobilize for war.
After the war with Europe in ruins
and growing tensions
with the Soviet Union,
the United States would
abandon isolationism
as a foreign policy,
in favor of membership
in the United Nations
and military interventions
to contain communism.
So this too is a major shift
from outright isolationism,
to imperialism,
to interventionism.
The events of the first
half of the 20th century,
changed the core belief that
the United States was better off
staying out of world affairs
into the belief that US
involvement was crucial
to maintaining order in world affairs.
So given the evidence we've compiled here,
which major events of the
first half of the 20th century
had the greatest impact
on national identity?
It seems like the aspects
of national identity
that changed the most were
the belief in individualism,
which transitioned into
a greater acceptance
of the role of government
in advancing citizen's welfare,
and the belief in isolationism,
which transitioned into the belief
that the United States should
intervene in world affairs.
Which events were most crucial
in changing those beliefs?
I would say that the Great Depression
was the most influential
in altering individualism,
and World War II was the most influential
in altering isolationism.
What do you think?
Would you come to the same
conclusions that I have?
Next, think about how you might
write a thesis statement in
order to answer this question
using the evidence that we've gathered.